you have to deal with the reality of the  situation dwelling and pondering and  crying doesn't do [ __ ] and it especially  doesn't do [ __ ] in this eco chamber in  this arena there is no crying you can  cry  you're just gonna lose and I bad news  about complaining and crying let me tell  you something about complaining and  crying that's really really gonna hurt  for all you complainers out there nobody  gives a [ __ ] and let me give you a  preview who gives a [ __ ] the following  people give a [ __ ] when you complain the  other losers around you you're sick  broken parent that secretly wants to  hold you down so that you're not more  successful than them and let me remind  you one more time the other [ __ ]  losers around you